hey guys it's Thursday the second last
day of the working week I'm Dan and this
is GameSpot news in case you've
forgotten that e3 is just under two
weeks away Ubisoft have released a
trailer for that III conference to get
you writing that swan boat of hype after
revealing that there will be a new
Assassin's Creed game soon far cry 5 is
coming in February and the crew is
getting a sequel you'll be right to
think that Ubisoft might not have much
else to show at e3
well Ubisoft CEO Yves Guillermo is here
to set you straight with a look at their
e3 conference sizzle reel let's fire it
up ah redacted wait all's not lost
though one of those redacted frames
teases the announcement of a new IP
which we know will be released in the
2018 to 19 fiscal year thanks to those
ever helpful earnings calls
there's also mention of Easter eggs
deemed a PRS during some South Park
fractured but whole shots and features
shown at conference that pops up in
between farc row 5 footage customizable
wallets maybe we'll be on the show for
covering everything III so make sure
you're subscribed and hey while you're
at it you can grab the game spot now app
on iOS and Android to get the 10 biggest
stories of the day delivered straight to
your conversation at bus stops avoider
that's your phone
I recently jumped back into Pokemon go
and I can't believe how much it's
changed since launch and it looks like
the changes are set to keep coming as
legendary Pokemon and PvP are set to
come sometime this summer in an
interview with Brazilian newspaper o
Globo translated by reddit users consti
and his uchi developer Niantic revealed
that the much requested PvP feature is
planned to hit this summer the feature
was delayed due to the quote large
success of the game Niantic went on to
tease other features saying right now we
are working on some that are due to hit
this summer in the northern hemisphere
such as giving more value to the choice
of the teams releasing legendary Pokemon
and introducing PvP non Tex global
marketing product lead our cat Bhargava
also teased the inclusion of legendary
Pokemon during his acceptance speech at
the 21st annual webby awards saying this
summer will be legendary he could just
be buying a slip and slide though let me
know which Pokemon you want to see added
to Pokemon go and if you can make it to
the black racks after school so we can
PvP so to end on some bad news but
Middle Earth shadow of war has been
delayed the sequel to 2014 shadow of
Mordor was originally scheduled to
launch in August but has now been pushed
to October 10 in a blog post develop a
monolith explained the delay was to
ensure the game delivers quote the
highest quality
experience they went on to apologize for
the quote difficult decision to move our
launch date to ensure that the game will
deliver on that promise but don't fret
they signed off their post by saying
we're excited to show more at e3 so you
can look forward to that
and that's it for today do enjoy the
rest of your day or the whole day that
is ahead of you and we will see you
tomorrow for our top 5 stories of the
entire week